[Music]
so an Quinn's ideas I strive to be
accurate with my content and to portray
the books that I talk about in a
meaningful and thoughtful manner but
mistakes sometimes occur and that is
exactly what happened in my most recent
three body problem and in my opinion
this mistake is egregious enough for me
to make this kind of addendum video to
clear things up so long story short in
my most recent video I talked about the
wall facers in the remembrance of
Earth's past Trilogy and in that video I
talk about Bill hin I talk about Manuel
re Diaz I talk about Lu G and I talk
about fr Frederick Tyler and it is in my
section where I discuss Frederick
Tyler's plan that I make a crucial era
and first I'm going to explain the era
and why it happened so essentially in
the video Tyler is portrayed as a double
agent rather than a triple agent which
is what he is Frederick Tyler never had
any intent on helping etto he actually
had implanted bombs inside the comicazi
fighters and he intended to detonate
those bombs harming the trican fleet and
killing those members of etto this final
but crucial part of Frederick Tyler's
plan was completely missing from my
video and I deeply apologize because it
fundamentally changes everything about
his story and I don't know how I miss
this so I write all the scripts for
Quinn's ideas videos myself and then
those scripts go through an editing
process and in that editing process
sometimes things are rearranged and
change then I take that edited script
and I record the audio for the videos
and usually when I'm recording audio for
videos it's in the middle of the night
it's pretty late and this particular
video was a pretty late session and I
did not notice the change in the script
now I don't want to make any excuses
it's really all on me I should have
recognized this way earlier and I should
have corrected the problem in the script
before I edited the video and sent it
out so I again truly apologize the one
thing I absolutely do not want to do is
create misleading or false content and
this is just a quite frankly just a very
egregious mistake for something that's
laid out quite clearly in the text the
giant chunk of ice would be propelled by
the mosquito group the mosquito Fleet
would likely draw very close to the
Lord's Fleet when presenting the gift at
which point the second consequence of
the failure of your attempt to build a
kamakazi force would be put to use that
failure prompted your very logical
request for independent control of the
entire mosquito Fleet when Earth's Fleet
draws close to the Lord's Fleet you
would take control of the fighters from
the etto pilots and switch them to drone
mode ordering the fighters to strike
their chosen targets the super bombs
will be detonated at Point Blank Range
annihilating all of the Lord ships
Frederick Tyler obviously was not a
Trader as the text clearly shows so I
really hope you guys can forgive me for
this era and I hope that you can
appreciate the fact that I'm trying to
correct my mistake here as always thanks
for watching I very much appreciate you
all